sometimes the other sister wives haven't
been so accepting of robin and her kids
i think that at the beginning it was
really hard blending families together
is really difficult and there were a lot
of frustrations
and hurt feelings on both sides of it i
mean we all came out of this guard all
of us did
but no i never had any intention to
alienate robin or her kids why does he
feel that way
i mean there's this sort of pecking
order it's it's like mary was really
hard on janelle and then janelle and
mary were hard on christine and then
jamella and mary and christine were hard
on robin
and robin's like going well i didn't do
this to you i didn't do this why are you
this way
and frankly other than mary i'm not sure
that the others would ever want to be
her friend
you know because i
had a conversation with janelle recently
where i said hey let's
let's um
let's figure this out you know
i want the good sister-wife relationship
i know they exist
and
she she kind of said well you know i
i'll have to think about that
yeah there is some history there in the
past that i i mean my my desire is there
yeah but i'm kind of like oh do i want
to do this again do you know what i mean
so
but it's true like i felt like um in
this particular conversation i felt like
i was kind of being put on the spot and
i'm like i don't know i don't know
you know
but what do you want do you want to have
a relationship with her that's a little
bit deeper maybe a relationship that you
have with christine
yes i think so but i don't know
yeah i just don't know like i don't know
how to because christie and i were like
it was just kind of one of those things
that happened because we were raising
kids together
i kind of feel like
you really are the only one that's
having a fully functioning relationship
with cody
and
that must
bother them
makes me angry
sorry
sorry
gosh how am i gonna get it for this
why does that make you so angry you said
gosh this makes me so angry
i just don't know why they're not
figuring this stuff out
[Music]
you